regardez ces images qu'on vous présente
des robots tueurs doté d'une
intelligence artificielle stone thème
évidemment qui est récurrent science
fiction mais vous voyez cette vidéo qui
est en réalité une simulation commandé
par des groupes qui s'opposent au
développement des robots tueurs parce
qu'ils trouvent que c'est trop dangereux
que c'est éthiquement même inacceptable
alors ils font circuler ce genre de
vidéos pour faire la conscientisation le
monde réalise pense quoi exactement
les grandes puissances comme les
etats-unis la russie la chine développe
semble-t-il déjà par le biais de grands
géants comme amazon com microsoft comme
intel ce genre d'intelligence
artificielle au service de la mort ni
plus ni moins d'ailleurs les etats-unis
ont déjà affirmé faire une priorité de
l'intégration d'intelligence
artificielle dont le personnel militaire
comme quoi si on veut rester dans les
puissants on ne peut pas passer à côté
de ça alors ça soulève évidemment
tellement de questions j'entende avec
mon prochain invité marc antoine le
diacre et professeur adjoint en éthique
et philosophie politique et chercheur
associé au milan le centre de recherche
en intelligence artificielle à montréal
bonsoir monsieur jack
mais ça c'est effrayant quand on regarde
ça d'abord si on commence par exigence
artificielle appliquée aux technologies
militaires au broad soir c'est quoi sert
exactement
alors il ya différentes choses d'abord
il faut il faut distinguer le matériel
et l'immatériel donc le matériel se sont
effectivement des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle embarqués
dans des dents des robots dans des
systèmes physiques automatisé et puis il
y à l'immatériel dont on parle rarement
qui en réalité concerne tous les
systèmes de collecte des données de
reconnaissance mais aussi d' attaque à
l'égard d'autres systèmes informatiques
donc c'est toute cette panoplie là qu'on
appelle les armes les armes autonome et
on distingue les armes aux autonomes qui
sont tueuse des hommes de tom qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas tueuse mais qui
vont servir par exemple faire une
attaque sur un système informatique
parce que c'est ça il ya plusieurs
façons faire des attaques maintenance et
on s'en prend entre entreprises ou entre
puissance entre pays
les questions éthiques elles sont
énormes dites moi actuellement
quelles règles lie les pays en matière
de droit de tuer est ce que ça prend
encore l'intervention d'un humain dans
le processus décisionnel
alors ça c'est une question qui est qui
des battues qui est débattu depuis trois
quatre ans avec la notion d'un contrôle
humain véritable donc c'est meaningful
kim and control en anglais et ses bas
lors meaningful c'est quelque chose de
authentique de véritables de deux quais
bien contrôle réel on est on est mal à
l'aise avec cette notion là on sait pas
très bien comment la définir on sait pas
très bien comment la définir
philosophiquement et on sait encore
moins bien la définir du point de vue
juridique
or c'est dans les enceintes juridiques
notamment les anciens internationale
qu'on discute de cette question là le
groupe d'experts de l'onu sur la
convention des armes conventionnelles
alors c'est étrange parce que on à faire
aujourd'hui des hommes qui sont non
conventionnés conventionnelle avec
l'intelligence artificielle mais ce
groupe d'experts et bien depuis trois
ans mais cette notion d'un contrôle
humain au coeur de ces recherches est au
coeur des négociations mais il n'y a
toujours pas de consensus sur 7 sur
cette notion là
pourquoi n'y a pas de consensus
probablement parce que d'abord parce que
cette notion est difficile un contrôle
humain à kehl à quel degré et puis à
quel endroit de la chaîne à quel endroit
de la chaîne de commandement
si on parle d'armes autonome forcément
parler d'un contrôle humain devient
presque antinomiques ce c'est presque
contradictoire de parler d'un contrôle
avec des armes qui sont par ailleurs par
ailleurs autonomes parce que le robot
tueur avec une intelligence artificielle
en réalité par le biais de
reconnaissance faciale si j'ai bien
compris enfin avec ses différentes
technologies aurait pas besoin d'aucune
intervention humaine
on lui donne un mandat s'ils veulent
l'appliquer peu importe ce qui se passe
ça ça roule tout seul
en gros c'est vide et c'est ce que c'est
ce que
les les ingénieurs en armement et s'est
essayé de faire en revanche on sait
aussi que ces armes ne sont pas
totalement autonome et surtout parce
qu'il ya la question de ce qu'on peut
faire mais aussi la question de ce qu'on
doit faire et nous ce qu'on dit que ce
soit dans la déclaration de montréal
pour un développement responsable
l'intelligence artificielle que ce soit
dans la déclaration d'asile omar qui a
été signé en 2010 est ce qu'on dit c'est
que il faut que la responsabilité reste
attribuable à un être humain c'est à
dire que peu importe le degré
d'autonomie du système d'intelligence
artificielle
ce sont les humains qui sont
responsables de leur déploiement est ce
que on sait où on en est rendu dans la
création de ses armes avec intelligence
artificielle ou est-ce qu'un grain
secret parce que quand je lisais que des
grandes entreprises
vous savez quand on parle d' amazon
d'accord on parle de microsoft j'ose
dire c'est des entreprises on achète
leurs produits mais on sait pas qu'en
achetant leurs produits pendant ce temps
là ils sont en train de travailler sur
ce genre de truc leur s qui ont des
comptes non ils n'ont pas de compte à
rendre en tout cas pas auprès de leurs
de leur public peu près de leurs clients
ils ont certainement des comptes à
rendre auprès de leurs employés et une
entreprise dont le cas est un peu
exemplaire c'est google qui a essayé de
travailler sur des projets d'armement et
qui a subi la contestation au sein même
de son entreprise pour ce sont des
entreprises sont extrêmement grande avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'employés et on peut
évidemment compter sur les engagements
éthiques de des employés de ces de ces
compagnies google a dû faire marche
arrière
probablement qu après les annonces
publiques qu'on a eu
concernant amazon et
microsoft il y aura certainement un
ajustement une réaction de la part de la
direction mais c'est sûr que ce n'est
pas suffisant parce que il n'y a pas de
véritable contrôle sur leurs sur leurs
affaires et la seule manière de réguler
c'est ce développement est ce
déploiement des armes des armes non
autonomes
c'est l'an passé tout simplement au
niveau d'une juridiction internationale
alors aujourd'hui c'est l'onu qui sans
qu'ils s'en occupent mais il faudra de
toute façon qu'il y ait un accord des
grandes puissances et pas simplement un
accord de le ddd petit pays mais deux
des grands puis c'est grave soit pas se
faire masser américains au sens et les
russes les rues selon ne l'ont pas caché
il ya deux ans en effet les leaders de
l'intelligence artificielle dominera le
monde peu importe que ce soit vrai mais
c'est le s'emballer mais si ça ce n'est
vraiment pas comme cela qu'on n'aurait
pas parlé longtemps merci beaucoup
mesdames messieurs mais il sauve à être
de retour dès lundi au revoir à bientôt